all right so this is the challenge
keenan
is guarding casey
[Music]
i counted him i counted him what
happened that time keenan
he's stealing my [ __ ] now
what up everybody lufco here and it is
time for underrated sponsored by state
farm an incredible company with
surprisingly great rates
just like this show is hopefully home to
some surprisingly great madden ratings
and our guest today is the surprisingly
great casey hayward
but i'm unsurprisingly annoyed at his
madden ratings
let's get a ratings adjuster on the line
hey jake call madden let's do this
calling madden ratings adjuster
look at that hat look at that face clint
oldenburg
what a legend good to see you pal hey
adam how you doing
this whole chargers team i think is
underrated i got casey hayward
cornerback good friend of mine we went
to kindergarten together
he's good at defending wide receivers
what about wide receiver traits what
about
release can we bump that up you know
he's throwing these curve balls at us
man i don't know why
is he planning on maybe running a
franchise where he switches his position
to receiver or something
that's not something you need to worry
about i just asked you a yes or no
question can we improve it
maybe we'd have to you know we have to
see evidence you're about to
hey jake call casey hayward
calling casey hayward
[Music]
there he is my guy casey hayward this is
clint oldenburg
man how you doing look i'm gonna jump
right into it okay putting all your
ratings up on the screen time to go to
work
if you see what i see i'm looking at 90s
across the board and nearly all of your
core skills
you got to be feeling that i agree with
that they got they got all those
my change of direction my route
recognition that's all up that to a par
and yet your overall does not reflect
that i'm like
what could be holding this man back and
to me
i think it's your speed at 89. it
probably might be even though it's at
89.
you know i don't really get ran by that
much i don't get ran by that much clint
speed i want to almost race him against
his own character what do we think
i would love to see that actually uh but
our speed rating is literally what is
the top end speed of each individual
player this can go up this can go down
right
yes absolutely with speed it can be very
fluid
okay i'm gonna get you this footage
we're gonna turn that fluidity
into a solid not sure what that means
but you got footage coming your way
all right we'll be on the lookout for it
casey versus madden casey
20 yards and i am ready
three two one
go
[Music]
from my perspective man you were looking
blazing fast
how did it feel i hope i'm tired how
many times a game do you do a 20-yard
all-out sprint for me maybe like 40
of the game all right man whenever
you're ready uh we're gonna need you to
do it again okay
i got one more okay
let's make this the one casey on my mark
three two one go
[Music]
let's hope that was faster than my guy
it's a tough call
so casey i was saying earlier when we
were looking at your db skills all of
your core skills are still rated really
high
so i went through the rest of your
ratings and i thought why not give your
overall a boost
by going after one of your lower ratings
and i picked
release and i knew we were gonna need
some help with that
so hey okay how you feeling about doing
something
release drills something cause i feel
like my press db skills is still like
that from high school you know i was the
number one guy so
i really feel like i can get after you a
little bit all right so this is the
challenge
are we accepting let's do it man i was
hoping you'd say that
because i took the liberty of mocking up
an epic battle in madden where
keenan is guarding casey and this is
what we got take a look
oh my god you said he got a 12 release
and he's sliding on me he got you there
man
nice b number two
that's one one one oh
now that you know the drill casey you're
going to get five snaps
and five yards to shake keenan but your
your [ __ ] might go down if i kill you my
press
yes what's my press keenan it doesn't
matter
i'm sorry this episode it is all about
casey
let's do it
[Music]
okay get him on his heels get him on his
heels
get him on his heels one one what
happened that time keenan
tried to pan i tried to do the pat pete
[ __ ] a little quick it didn't work it
didn't work
all right third battle let's get it
going
and the high school all-american holds
strong in round number three
that's the one
and casey just barely edges keenan out
let's go let's go let's go
that was some of my [ __ ] he's stealing
my [ __ ] now all right casey so it is
2-2 yeah what is the move
that you're thinking will get him to
bite i might go back with the same move
i just got him he's not gonna think i'm
gonna do it again so he doesn't think
you're gonna go scissors twice in a row
now we thinking okay it sounds soft
[Music]
good man you need help you need help
[Music]
counted him yeah counted him and i
counted him that's what i'm talking
about casey
these ratings are flying up i was 12 i
got to go up
keenan man big ups to you dude coming
out helping us today appreciate it man
get my boy right get him right all right
casey
you put some great stuff on film today
we're gonna get these ratings up casey i
promise
clint i told you he put it on film
give me the breakdown what do we think
hey i was really happy to watch casey on
film
you know it's always nice to get up
close and personal with some of these
guys and get some more information
just want to call out one of the ratings
that he really cares about the most is
one of the hardest in madden to improve
a lot of people argue with you guys
about speed huh
yes speed is the one that players care
about the most
let's get casey hayward on the phone
right now yo yo yo yo what's going on
casey man i have next to me is the
ultimate madden plug he is the ratings
adjuster what's up claire man
casey welcome really appreciate you
taking the time to put yourself
on film for us to do some further
evaluation oh for sure man i appreciate
it i know
i know the speed is the hardest one to
adjust i'm glad i was able to put a
little bit on film i didn't give my all
on the run
i hope it didn't drop that's all that
matters uh really what we noticed was
was casey seemed like he was unable to
really go
full speed and likely that's because
he's got an nfl schedule to worry about
so based on what we watch that speed
rating is not going to change at all
i'm okay with that i'm okay with that
okay
i'm okay with that because i wasn't even
fresh you don't want to push it too hard
we understand yeah yeah
i gotta talk to you clint now let's take
us to release because i know that what
he was doing on kena was special
yeah actually we were we were pretty
impressed with the release stuff
you know really impressed even though uh
you know only won three out of five
he's actually gonna go up 25 points in
the release rating because
that's what i need needed my points to
go up not my speed i'm okay with that
give me my release stuff
plint i have to ask you now was casey
hayward
underrated casey hayward was underrated
on the offensive side of the ball other
than that i think we got him pretty good
here
and there is clint the only thing he
defends better than casey hayward on
passes
is his ratings we'll take it no we're
gonna
think oh and there you have it from
state farm surprisingly great rates to
casey hayward's surprisingly great
ratings thank you
for checking out underrated
you like what you just saw subscribe to
bleacher port on youtube for more
underrated